couples when you separate your finances
you're separating something that's
supposed to be unified you marry someone
you are sharing your life not in this
like codependent way of you know all
that like you're still going to be who
you are but when you separate that and
you guys don't work together with your
finances I'm telling you there's stuff
that you guys are avoiding and you end
up being roommates that there's a level
of intimacy that is created and
vulnerability when you say I I
everything I have is yours everything
you have is mine and we're a team we're
married like it should be us against the
world and instead you're in this like
triangle with the world trying to dance
around it and it's exhausting so your
marriage will be Thrive it will be so
much richer and deeper if you guys work
on the same team